thanks for thanks everyone for coming
out uh I'm really excited to have this
group here to talk about open source and
python I'm going to let each individual
uh introduce themselves but I'll give a
quick introduction introduction for my
myself before we get going so I'm Xander
I'm the CEO and founder of a company
called bite wax we do
python open source stream processing
project if you want to check it out
I'm from Santa Cruz and I'm excited to
be here this is my first time at Pi data
Seattle but I've been to some other Pi
data events and this is pretty awesome
so I'll turn it over and let them all
introduce themselves and then we kind of
have a couple topics we're going to talk
about and we'll see how the time goes if
we have time I hope to open it up for a
couple questions but the debate might
get Fierce so we might not have enough
time
um hi everyone I'm Juanita I am a PhD
student at EUC Santa Cruz and on my free
time I am also the community manager for
the Scientific Python project
um so it aims to basically coordinate
and integrate the Scientific Python
ecosystem sort of like bring together
the libraries and find ways to
um sort of make it easier for us to
coordinate
and I met Sandra in Santa Cruz a few
months ago and I'm very excited about
documentation and Community Building
within open source so I'm hoping to talk
about that a little bit today
um I'm Hamlet Hussein I
work on a lot of Open Source projects
maintain a wide variety of Open Source
projects of one that I've been involved
with recently is called nbdev
it's a project that allows you to write
distribute and test python packages
from Jupiter notebooks
so if that sounds crazy or sounds
interesting give it a shot
hi I'm Stefan kravchick the CEO and
founder of dagwix at dag Works we're
trying to solve the pain that you feel
when you inherit someone else's model
pipeline code
we are driving an open source project
called Hamilton which I created at
Stitch fix which is essentially an
opinionated way to write python that
helps with that otherwise yeah I'm based
in San Francisco so excited to be my
first in-person Pi data and my
introduction to python was uh way back
in the day at grad school I didn't
really pick it up until I had to use it
for work so thanks
my
my name is Katrina real I'm the
president of the board of directors for
numb Focus hopefully all of you know who
numb focus is we are the fiscal entity
for most of like about 60 projects in
the pi data ecosystem about 50
Affiliated projects and we also put on
the pi data conferences so you're all at
our event and I'm also an adjunct
lecturer at Georgetown University and I
just recently became the maintainer of
the pi Vis project I've been around in
the community for a really long time I
started using python in about 1998
and uh made the rounds at all The Usual
Suspects from enthot to Anaconda to
everywhere so I recently retired and so
I am here just uh hanging out and
hopefully going to attend as many Pi
data events as I possibly can and uh
dear open source so that is my whole
story
all right so what I want to get started
here with is you all have been involved
in the python ecosystem in one way or
another for a long time
and I want to touch or want you all to
touch on some of the trends that you see
today that are really impacting
the python ecosystem and then maybe talk
a little bit about areas that you don't
that you think don't receive sufficient
support today
and
anyone can jump in and take it to start
okay I'm gonna jump in
um I'm just coming from pycon so I have
a whole lot of juice on this one
actually
um you know I've actually been thinking
about this quite a bit in the sense that
you know Python's been around for a
while now right
um it's you know created in what 1991.
um it's got a large community around it
now
um there's a point in time where you
start to wonder okay is this too big has
this become too big a library do we have
too many things in the standard Library
have we moved in too many different
directions is python the right solution
for a lot of the applications that we're
working on right now right I think that
one person put it really really well
that you know python is good for a lot
of things but it's not necessarily the
best tool for everything right and so
um
is there a chance here like has our
standard Library gotten too big do we
have too many different ways for us to
do the same thing right for example
don't get me started on threads and
async IO and all of the fun stuff going
on there right
um is this really necessary and do we
have enough consensus in our community
in order to move together in One
Direction
also this happens also in the scientific
community and I'm just going to say you
know the big bomb in the scientific
Community is data science right this is
big business this has come in and really
uh using a lot of the tools that have
been out there in the Sci-Fi Community
for a long time which were primarily you
know developed mostly by physicists and
geophysicists and bench scientists right
and so when we're moving into this new
area where is the science going right
are we still supporting the scientific
Community as well as we could and are we
also you know moving in the right
direction
for supporting these these companies and
a lot of the data science that's going
on and what does that relationship look
like there's a lot of gap between the
support in both of those areas and where
does that line belong and are we really
in the position where we want people
giving their free time and doing free
work on open source software so that
others can make millions and billions of
dollars off of it right so
um I'm just going to start there
I was going to say so uh having worked
at Stitch fix for close to six years I
was going to say off of the the data
science thing uh you know the the
ecosystem of tooling for you know doing
machine learning has gone so much better
um and so uh I've definitely been one of
those who have uh uh not taken advantage
but um utilize all the open source uh
things to help data scientists and you
know obviously the company at Stitch fix
make more money
um and so I think uh for me in my career
I've really seen uh the uh the machine
learning side and also the data side
really also gravitate towards python so
that means a lot of the glue language is
in the glue code python actually becomes
a really uh a great way to glue things
together
um uh and then uh in terms of you know
gaps and things uh having tried to build
tooling for data scientists is really
packaging is really still I think
something that python could do a much
better job of if you compare it to other
languages like go or something which
make it kind of really easy to kind of
build something and then distribute it
python has like so many ways and so when
I look at someone who has who's using
poetry versus basil I kind of you know
my eyes glaze over and I really just
want something super simple but
um otherwise you know that's kind of my
experience of the trends of uh uh with
with python right now
um yeah I was gonna say um related to
what you were mentioning that maybe this
sort of um
like trend of guiding into different
directions is caused by the fact that
there's not like an awareness of the
tools that there are and maybe some sort
of um materials that help us learn how
to integrate them together and how to
um make like a
like a coherent workflow with each of
these tools
um and so I I wanted to say that maybe
one of these gaps within the python
ecosystem it's um this like tutorials or
documentation regarding like how to use
these tools that we're building and how
to integrate it in our workflow together
like why not
um yeah maybe there are documentation
for each of the libraries non-by-side by
like there's a bunch of documentation
for all them but is there materials that
can help me do something specifically
with all of them together and how to
like make my workflow Easier by using
them all and not like Reinventing the
will of like creating a new package that
that does everything that all of them
together do
um
and the other thing that it's also
related to this is
um I think by this point that we have
like so many libraries coordination
between them would be like important in
the sense that
um why does each one of the Python
libraries has to have their own I don't
know documentation theme
um why not just have one theme and then
like we all coordinate and we use them
together and I don't know I'm
um yeah I'm pushing towards this idea of
like working together integrating the
the libraries to be like a a bigger
group it might be very hard because
there's a bunch of them but I think we
can start somewhere on like coordinating
on this like little things that can make
it easier to find like a single workflow
with all of them
yeah I agree with everything that was
said
um you know two kind of pain points that
I keep coming across
out of all the companies I work for and
various open source projects is
you know it's packaging and
documentation systems it's like
documentation systems or especially
painful
um you know every project kind of tries
to go down their own path you know
there's Sphinx but
people want you know beautiful modern
looking documentation they want kind of
features that support things like
Jupiter notebooks in them and all kinds
of stuff and
it's kind of a mess to you know everyone
ends up rolling their own documentation
system
and I think
yeah that's one thing that bothers me a
lot personally because I think
documentation is extremely important
and uh do each of you have a particular
project uh or a python Library that's
particularly exciting for you right now
and you can't just uh shell out whatever
it is you're working on
well I'm I'm part of the Scientific
Python project so I'm of course biased
uh but I think that the this is like a
very good opportunity to start this like
integration so right now we're working
on uh something called like specs which
is similar to like nips or like all this
uh specification documents for libraries
but this is something that we want to do
in a more General sense that would work
for like more than one library and we're
working on like a system where the
libraries can like boat for like
whatever policies they think would like
favor them and I think this is like a
very excitement like start Point towards
this integration
um I I think also the sort of involving
the community in this process it's very
important too so I'm very excited about
what I'm doing right now actually
yeah I guess it's unfair to ask me like
what my favorite python packages or what
I'm most excited about so okay mbdev is
really exciting to me because
um you know right now when you write
python code you kind of have to live in
Two Worlds you live in your Rebel and
then the IDE you kind of have to context
switch between those
I think that's a really painful
experience
and mbdev offers like a window and into
which Both Worlds can coexist
in a really interesting way and it's
very experiential it's hard for me to
even explain it you have to experience
it
even if you don't use mvdav I recommend
kind of
playing with it so you can experience
that modality and it's not just about
rep Rebel and
you know your IDE and context switching
it's also a documentation system
and so
yeah like you know like building
documentation into your workflow as a
first class thing is you know is is
really cool too
um
and so there's another project that's
correlated
um
called quarto which I'm really excited
about it integrates a lot of you know
scientific uh kind of publishing
Computing allows you to generate
document documentation in various
formats
um but you know and it supports
notebooks and all kinds of other stuff
and it's very rich and it's sort of
functionality and
yeah I've uh helped people produce
documentation sites with it already
um that it has very customized and
beautiful and you know works well with
python and so mbdev is also built on top
of that too which is why I mentioned it
so yeah those are two things I'm kind of
excited about
so I'm pretty utilitarian so I guess
it's hard to get me excited but uh um
when I'm thinking or at least building
python projects actually I uh one of the
the packages I always use and have is
black so black is the formatter and I
think uh related to you know how you
structure and manage code having
something that takes takes a lot of the
opinionate or provides an opinion uh
stops fights between people or even
people over code so um you know that's
at least you know one of my favorite
libraries I guess in Python you know I'm
happy to evangelize
as the president of the board of
directors of numb Focus I feel like I
should not talk about which one are my
favorite projects I think that all 20
120 of our projects are amazing they are
all doing fantastic things
um but I will actually go outside of
that a little bit the projects I
honestly have been keeping my eye on
quite a bit are Pi script is one of them
that I think is just absolutely amazing
what they're doing over there as a
result of that also piadite is just
under the hood of Pi script they're also
doing a lot of really really cool things
visu is actually one I've been keeping
my eyes on I know that uh there you are
like I don't know how many of y'all
caught that tutorial but we've been
talking for a little bit I think there's
some amazing things happening over on
that project and then also just as far
as like code quality and linters and
things like that rough is actually my my
favorite thing right now it's uh taking
the place of so many things in my tool
stack
um that I just have to shout that one
out rough is amazing
right on so uh Katrina you mentioned a
little earlier
um about you know how long python's been
around for and how big it has become
um you know it's been one of the fastest
growing languages and ranks top five on
whatever analysis or
um site you look at it's in the top five
for most widely used languages
why do you each one of you
um why do you think that is what are
some insights into why python has become
as widely adopted as it has become
um so I actually was thinking about this
quite a bit during pycon Guido actually
was talking about in his closing
arguments or arguments you know what I
mean
um he was talking about uh that python
is the people's programming language I
think that's a really really good way to
put it it's the accessibility it's the
community it's the ability to be able to
extend the language it's the ability to
be able to do really whatever you want
within python which is one of the things
that really attracted me to it right was
that
suddenly I was in the position where you
know python is so closely tied to the
open source community that I was really
only
Bound by my the amount of time I was
willing to take to try to do something
right is easily extensible it was easy
to work with it was easy to learn easy
to explain all of those things like that
even if it wasn't necessarily the
fastest right or it wasn't necessarily
the right tool that was needed for
absolutely every job but it was
something that
came about through the work of a lot of
people and I also look at this also the
you know the the size of the community
and also the size of the libraries the
size of you know the whole Pi data
ecosystem the standard Library all these
things like that I actually think
to be quite honest is a positive thing
right this is the independent Spirit of
Open Source at work right is that the
whole idea behind open source is that if
you have an idea you can run with it
that you're able to take your ideas and
create them and put them out there and
put those ideas out for everybody else
and somehow you know our Collective
Brain Trust we get to better Solutions
over time and so when I look at
something like this I look at the fact
that this is going to continue that
we're going to continue to get better
that there are going to be solutions
that come out of there there is a
possibility that you know they'll clean
out the standard Library someday but it
this is uh I think that the all of the
mechanisms are in place for us to be
able to continue to move forward that
way
yeah um so yeah for me when I was
reflecting on this question or thinking
about it
um uh the one thing that came to mind is
job interviews uh so one thing that
really stuck for me was that uh python
you could it's you can be really concise
and really fast at expressing something
that you can't in other languages uh and
that really uh was ham at home to me
when I was on the interview circuit you
know a decade ago uh you know five six
years ago right that um uh python is a
great is a great interview language
because if you can do things shorter and
write it out sooner and faster your
interview perception is much better
because you've completed the task much
sooner and so to me that really speaks
to the strengths of python is that you
can actually write a code quickly have
it be understandable and to really you
know uh you know uh the fastest way from
your brain to computer right is you know
python is one a pretty good way to
express yourself
uh the other is uh um you know the one
reason another reason to add on to uh
Katrina was saying that why it's so
large is this ecosystem right uh in the
last decade has just gone bigger and
bigger I remember you know python 2 uh
right and all the issues with it but
then Python 3 I feel like things really
accelerated
um uh and so it's been you know great to
see uh for people who've been building
kind of internal uh companies you have
to pick a language right and you have to
choose a language that you want your
team to use and orientate around and so
like one of the it's a bit of I think a
network effect is Rich get richer
because of Python's ecosystem it's hard
to bet against it because there's
generally going to be some solution or
something there within the ecosystem
that can solve your problem and so I
think it's you know yeah it's been
snowballing I guess on itself so
yeah I've heard it all this phrase that
um people Comfort the language but they
say for the community and I think that's
absolutely true I think that python it's
like a like relatively easy language to
learn like that's
um it has like a lot of advantages in
terms of like the language itself but I
feel like at least in my case I well I
made Python and I started coming to this
event and it kind of it's kind of really
easy to get very inspired to what people
are doing here like you meet amazing
People You Meet the maintainers of your
favorite libraries and you're like wow I
can be I can do that I can I can start
building my own stuff and that doesn't
happen in like all the ecosystems like
this is like super
um cool about the python ecosystem is to
come to buy data or sci-fi or pycon and
meet these amazing people and just like
be able to know that you can build your
your things here on on your own and get
the help from people like I I remember
that one of the like most memorable
experience for me was the Sprints at
like a side by or something because
that's the first time that I actually
knew that I was actually going to be
able to do something by myself you know
like build my own Library so I think
that um the community in the python
ecosystem is amazing and that's what
makes it growing like faster
I don't think I have anything to add to
that
no worries um uh so at this point I want
to switch gears just a little bit uh and
start talking a bit more about Open
Source and I want to start with the
topic of funding and
and uh
I think it would be neat for you all to
share some experiences and then maybe
some opinions you have on
um
issues with funding for open source
projects and then maybe some solutions
that you've thought of or you're
currently approaching with something
you're building potentially
thanks
yeah I think about this every day
um
yeah I actually don't know if there's
like a great set of solutions that I've
stumbled upon
as far as funding for open source I mean
you know so like
you know like maintaining open source
projects and a lot of times feel like a
very thankless task I mean it's initial
High when you release a project but then
very quickly
you know you're like maintaining issues
and you know you're doing it for free
and so
um you know the topic of funding
definitely comes up a lot we've tried to
make many different things so mbdev is
currently in this GitHub accelerator
program
so we had some you know sponsorship from
GitHub
um you know tried Consulting around that
I've done that for a bit
um definitely thought about you know
sort of
having some commercial entity around it
as well
um so I've explored all of those things
um I haven't really explored the
commercial entity yet
um you know there's probably Xander or
or some of these other folks can talk
about it but
yeah I actually don't have a great
answer to that
um
it is seems like it does seem like a
problem in some sense I I wish that
there would be more of a Marketplace for
let's say you know
maintainers to to like transact with
people you know right now kind of on our
own to sort of find funding and I don't
think sponsors is not the GitHub
sponsors or something like that
is is you know not enough I think there
could be richer types of
modalities in which we could transact
with each other
I think maybe
um
well this is just my thoughts but maybe
the lack of funding comes from like
the lack of awareness of how important
like most of these libraries are like I
feel like there's a lot of companies and
projects that make tons of money by
using like Scientific Python libraries
like like all the python packages
available that are open source and the
money that they give to open source is
not like comparable to that right so
they they have a lot of money that they
make using our libraries for free but
they they don't contribute the same way
and I feel like it's like a yeah they
they don't recognize how important it is
to like use these libraries and I I have
been lucky of being able to be funded
for working open source and I think
there's like very nice um like
initiatives and grants and like there's
stuff out there that you can use to fund
open source work
um but the amount of use that it has
it's not comparable to the amount of
money that it receives to be worked on
so I think that it's a tremendous Gap I
don't have a solution for it I think
that
um
there should be a way of
I don't know making making more clear
out there like the the importance of how
many times a library has been used for
like doing X or Y thing
um but yeah it's a it's a really like
bad gap between the money that you
produce with open source and the money
that you get for funding open source
work
yeah I was gonna say the the awareness I
think is uh me candidly being pretty
ignorant I want to say yeah I'm not
aware of yeah which which projects that
I use would want more funding so I
definitely think there's a bit of an
awareness issue uh the other is that
there's a lot of Open Source projects
that are in very different states uh
which I think also complicates a bit of
the issue so I know we're using
um some guys you know react component
that he's done on his spare time like uh
here's a little sponsor button like and
we know he's put it on his page that
like you know he is just him right and
so uh it helps a little bit with the
awareness but then there's you know
projects like you know like numpy I have
no idea you know how I could contribute
or what sponsorship would entail or
anything like that so I think there's a
bit of a uh you know a disconnect there
and then there's the
um I mean the best is having you know
some company spend something out but
obviously then uh you know and if they
can devote time to it then you know that
to use it as branding I think think so
Stitch fix where I used to work that's
one of the reasons why you know they
were excited to open source things
because it helped with branding and so
they were excited to kind of devote some
time there but those things don't last
forever so potentially you know that
funding source dries up and so uh you
might you know want to use some library
from some company but unfortunately that
maintain a left and so no one's there
who wants to kind of drive forward
within that organization getting that
time and resources so
um yeah hard problem
heterogeneous heterogeneity of you know
where the projects come from is part of
it but otherwise I know excited to hear
what Katrina might say
I was just going to say if you want to
give money to numpy you're welcome to go
to the num Focus website and give money
to numpy we are their fiscal sponsor
so I I have a lot to say about this
actually because before I was president
of the board of directors I was actually
the treasurer for numb focus by the way
so I've seen kind of where the bodies
are buried here and
um you know it I think it's kind of
amazing when you look at the impact that
open source has had out there in the
world in some cases even you know
driving whole parts of the economy how
difficult it is for us to find
sustainable funding for open source
projects and I think that also people
are very surprised when they find out
some cases how brittle an open source
project might be you have 10 core
developers that are all working on a
project that could be a huge part of
your company's infrastructure
but not anything is actually going into
that project no one's making sure that
the sustainability of that project is
taken into consideration when they look
at you know using that or having that
dependency in their stack and so I also
and I think people are always really
surprised by this by the way because I'm
constantly out stumping for money by the
way for all of the projects that are
under our umbrella in within the
community
everyone assumes that you know everyone
is super rich right but numpy is
obviously so well used and everyone is
aware of this that like all these people
must be making you know half a million
dollars a year and everything is just
going absolutely beautifully which is
not the case in a lot of cases most open
source uh developers are making below
average salaries in order to support
these things and it's also a scramble
every single year to even bring in the
money to be able to support those people
right and then you have the other ones
that have the Lesser projects the
smaller projects where people are just
doing this in their spare time that
they're just putting it out there
because we like to share ideas and we
like to share what we're all doing
but everyone kind of has this attitude
of like someone else is taking care of
that that you know oh obviously that
that project is getting money from
somebody right it's like when you scream
fire and everyone assumes someone else
called 9-1-1 it's like it's not actually
that that case and as far as Solutions
here actually I'm not I'm open to
anything anyone has to suggest by the
way we've talked about Partnerships
we've talked about
um you know better ways to fundraise
more services that we can offer
um just trying to figure out what is the
right way to do this but I also think
that the relationships between the open
source projects and corporate
sponsorships has always been a tenuous
one in a lot of cases the budgets that
we our people have to support open
source projects or events like this come
out of Marketing budgets which tend to
get slashed when there are contractions
in the economy so even if we have
Champions within engineering groups we
have people who are very much advocates
for everything that is going on in that
project they may not necessarily be the
decider of who can use that money or
have it in their budget for them to be
able to contribute to that project it'll
usually get deferred back over to to a
marketing team there's also turnover
right so we may have a really really
good relationship with one particular
company and then somebody else comes in
and has a completely different view of
the world and they decide that there's
no longer something that they want to
support
over on the institutional sponsors you
have the other side of things right
where my Sloan Foundation Chan
Zuckerberg initiative and Gordon and
Betty Moore Foundation are all really
active and they're fantastic but also
those grants
there are a couple different things
going on here right getting a grant can
be very very hard especially for people
who are not used to writing grants first
off
second off you need a grant
Administration administrator so it does
have to go through a fiscal entity for
example num Focus we do a lot of Grant
Administration
um but then also they tend to be very
feature oriented right that it's driving
something forward and not necessarily
always about maintaining the project
things like documentation Tech debt like
you know basically refactoring things
all of these things like that usually
are not going to be the best you know
proposals for you to put out there
that's not the big sexy new feature that
they want to fund and have their name on
and then to move a project forward so
and then there's also a scaling issue
here right if you have a smaller project
with like six maintainers on it and like
and you don't need all that much money
probably going to get looked over for
one of the larger ones they like to send
it a much much bigger chunks basically
but then you also on the other side of
here and trust me tell me to stop if I'm
just going on too much but um
we have this trend going on right now
where companies are being built around
open source projects which seems to be a
relatively sustainable way for things to
work where you're actually pulling in
money so there is this for-profit
you know support behind an open source
project
the problem here is that that usually
means that that company is controlling
the complete road map of that project so
you have the situation is that really
open source is that really Community
Driven is it still within the same vein
of what's going on here even if it is
more sustainable
that that way you actually do have money
coming in and what should that look like
um one of the other things that I also
just wanted to bring up is that a lot of
people have been talking about
um
you know how can we try to get people to
contribute back and so
first off I think that one that I'm
always talking to companies about is
paying developers out of their own
pocket to work on open source projects
even if it's just a couple days a week
this is a huge win so they're taking
care of their benefits and 401k and they
have you know career advancement and
management and all of these things like
that but then they also do have the work
that's happening on the projects
themselves which is a really really nice
and ways very very huge in-kind donation
giving money directly like I said can be
very challenging so doing something like
that is a very good thing to do but
um
uh the other thing I also want to
mention is that a lot of people within
the community lately have been talking
about are there licensing changes that
we can make right yeah this is coming up
more and more and more the more
conferences I go to and the more
conversations I'm having especially
since I mentioned before
data science is big business like people
are making a ton of money off of these
things and we have projects that are you
know scrounging for change in a lot of
ways
so what is the way that we can almost
Force responsibility back and does that
require some sort of Licensing change in
order to do that what would that look
like because it is hard to find people
that just out of the goodness of their
heart are willing to you know put this
out there and not even necessarily
because you're looking for name
recognition or you want to look like the
good guy you know there are a lot of
companies that want to do the absolute
bare minimum necessary for them to look
like they are a good actor in the open
source Community which is unfortunate
and of course we're you know very
grateful for anything that's coming in
but it's also not really within the
spirit of you know the community and how
we want to create a vibrant sustainable
community
so um with that I will stop there I was
gonna say I was gonna say one question
for you was um uh you kind of made me
think of Foundations yeah
uh how did would they play a part in
this or or not because there's also
there's a lot of different institutions
Linux Foundation Apache Etc uh do they
do any better than someone like a
commercial entities such as myself
um just kind of thinking yeah do you
think they have a role to play to help
standardize and push things in a certain
way it should all open source projects
be trying to push towards a foundation
type model or I'm just curious
I mean this is why num Focus was created
right so that people could get paid to
do open source that you do have we hold
the bank accounts for people and do all
the you know back end work for
um projects so that they are able to
focus on the technology right it's all
the stuff that nobody wants to think
about on the back end
um which is amazing you think about it
it's a bit of a revolutionary idea that
you have a Community Driven you know I'm
not a business person I'm not a back of
the office person I am a geek I am a PhD
in computer science who is like a
software developer and having something
that is Community Driven people who are
contributors to projects actually run
some sort of institution that does this
I think is actually a huge Revolution
and I'm not going to dog on other you
know foundations or anything like that
but you know the Linux Foundation is a
for-profit entity okay
the Apache Foundation doesn't run the
same way that num Focus does they have
the ability to be a physical sponsor but
it's not something it's not really a
responsibility that they want or that
they actually use I have a question yeah
yeah so about the you talked a little
bit about the licensing kind of things
going on and one kind of thought that
always crosses my mind is
this idea of begging for money
it doesn't ever doesn't seem sustainable
in any way this seems like that's the
modality that's like one modality of
like either getting grants
get up sponsors you name it all of that
kind of falls under begging for money
and I don't ever see that being a
situation where people can Thrive long
term there might be some past like
people out there that get lucky
but
yeah like what is your opinion on
licensing is that a promising Avenue
is there a way
to
kind of what do you is that going to get
traction what do you think dubious of
the licensing thing that just sounds
like you know pushing things into the
legal system is not really the best way
that we necessarily I I don't believe in
funding becoming punitive right that
this is uh I don't think that this is
the right way to go and that's my
personal opinion by the way so I'm just
gonna throw that out there this is very
Katrina opinion how can we stop begging
in like begging means like you know all
forms of begging asking for donations
asking for Grants you know anything like
that like how can we like is it yeah and
you have an opinion on that as a found
being a foundation yeah I mean because
we do I I don't like to think of myself
as a beggar but I mean we solicit funds
from a lot of different sources in order
to help out projects as much as possible
and try to put the projects out in front
as much as possible but we also do have
you know our own overhead running num
focus in order to be able to do all of
these things that we're doing
um but you know you do see the really
really successful projects you know it
goes back to that relationship I was
talking about that like if you have
company backing behind an open source
project you know it tends to be much
more stable
but you then have to at the expense of
possibly possibly the community or any
kind of road map right or is that such a
bad thing right because then you have
you tend to have a whole lot of
developers all coming to that same
company right so it could still be a
cross-pollination of ideas it's just all
within one Financial entity but I am
open to any and all suggestions by the
way of how we can get more money into
the open source Community 100 percent
does anyone have anything else to add
I was going to say the or the the
competitive so my uh uh running a
company uh so if you don't like the
Hamilton project since it's open source
you can Fork it if you don't like our
roadmap so I haven't seen too many
instances of that occurring in the wild
uh since I do think there is a bit of
friction to it but
um being you know you know here at this
conference you know we definitely do
want to push ideals in terms of you know
building a community since uh you know
uh I believe you know Hamilton will
Outlast my company very easily
um and so which case uh you know I
definitely want to kind of uh uh you
know encourage that and so I know I've
thought of things of like how can I show
that and I was like you know would it
could I show a badge on my repo that we
subscribe to some some sort of values
um I don't know if anyone actually has
that or does that I don't know or that
is something we have been discussing it
actually came up just this morning that
this is something we've talked about for
years that I think would be an amazing
thing to be able to say you know
numb Focus approved you know or that you
know that there's criteria that's being
met in order to be able to have that
kind of badge I think it would go a long
way
we're gonna get our blue check marks
well I mean because I was going to say
like with open source one of the hardest
things for adoption is actually
awareness right and so uh where my mind
goes with this if you have a curated
list right and then you teach people to
go to these lists then you know it's a
reinforcing mechanism right
yeah I agree I I think that it would be
amazing I you know I think
I think that we've gotten pretty good at
kind of the basics of what we're doing
right and those are the I I also just
want to mention on the educational
initiative is another thing that I think
that we would like to move into as well
so not just having you know corporate
sponsorships or you know corporate
Badges and things like that but also
having Partnerships with universities
that you know
um
I I think myself like a lot of other
open source developers you know we were
graduate students working on our
research and we decided to open source
all of the things that we were working
on as part of our research and that's
how we got involved in the open source
community so but then you graduate and
you get a mortgage and you have a job
and you join the brain drain of a
full-time job and suddenly the project
kind of becomes much more brittle so
having the ability to also support
students support you know this as an
Avenue for a career I think is an
important thing as well not to mention
the fact that you know money coming in
through you know educational areas I I
think that this is just a really good
conduit you know the the users of
tomorrow or the people that are in
schools today that's one of the reasons
that open source is so popular within
universities right now is because it's
freely available so students can take
advantage of it so the hope is of course
that these are going to become the
champions of Open Source when they leave
but we just keep running into the same
sort of obstacles
once once they get out
I was at a different panel
um
a few months ago and uh
um they were talking about one of the
one of the panelists was talking about a
course that they teach in the university
on how to contribute to open source so
we just talked about funding and how
funding can help maintainers stay
involved and the other thing you need
for an open source project to help it
continue is you can get resources via
contributors so what are some ways we
can make it easier for people to
contribute to open source I know myself
when I was a junior developer it was so
daunting to start to contribute to open
source it was just something that like
you you show up and it's like oh
everyone already has this figured out
the secret handshake is already there
how do I do this and so it felt like a
really big barrier of Entry so what are
some ways we can encourage contributions
to projects
yeah I think
contributing new projects
I just have a concrete suggestion is to
write documentation
that's the best way to contribute to a
project
um
maintainers really love it you learn
about the project and yeah like people
generally won't say no to that
um yeah and if yeah you'll learn a lot
about sort of what that project is and
you'll build trust and move on to other
things but I think it's a great way so I
got started yeah yeah I was just going
to add to that that is exactly the
advice I give to everybody when they ask
me how to join a project it's like if
you do documentation you'll become
everybody's best friend immediately and
that will remember your name and then
when you want to start actually
contributing not only are you familiar
with the code base after you've done all
this documentation but everyone will
also trust you more when your pull
request comes through right the other
thing I did want to mention also is that
a lot of projects have first time
contributor guides look for those
they're amazing and a lot of and other
projects I really love the projects that
tag issues that are really good for
first-timers they'll have you know like
a newbie tag on it or you know like a
first-time contributor tag on it or
something like that those are the ones
that are going to be very welcoming
they're the ones that like know that
this issue is one that probably someone
who hasn't contributed before are going
to be in there because I'll tell you you
know 20 years me contributing to open
source projects you gotta have a pretty
thick skin sometimes times when this you
know
contributions come in there so finding
the projects that are kind finding the
ones that are very open the ones that
have the guides the ones that have the
tags things like that are probably the
ones that you're going to look for and
that goes for the projects as well is
that if you do want more contributors
create those things create those avenues
for people to come in
um I think that
there's one thing that is also important
when creating documentation and it's
about thinking who you are creating
documentation for and I was actually
talking about this today
that documentation nowadays it's kind of
a hard thing with the audience that we
have like nowadays no one is going to
read a book no one's like actually takes
the time to maybe like read through a
whole website so if we really want to
actually target the people who are going
to start contributing to our open source
libraries tomorrow we need to think
about what kind of content they want to
see and how do they want to learn
because nowadays people are learning
very differently that they were 10 years
ago and the documentation that we have
for our open source libraries most of
them are already like very out today in
terms of how they're built like nowadays
people do tutorials they do like 30
second Tick Tock videos where they teach
how to do a PR on GitHub and that's what
people are actually using to learn and
as open source maintainers we actually
have to start thinking about that and
it's kind of a yeah it's it's going to
be really hard because that sort of
content it's probably more difficult to
sustain than like regular documentation
but if we really want to help people to
actually
know how to contribute to open source
and learn how to use our libraries we
need to think about how we write
documentation and the like yeah nowadays
I would say videos tick tocks gives
screenshots
Hands-On tutorials and that that would
be like the the one thing I would say
that it's super important right now to
think about
yeah I was going to say I've been
thinking about video documentation
um the one thing for getting started I
think uh for me is like the the number
of steps should be as minimal as
possible so if you have a script that
you could collapse a bunch of steps
together write that script because
nothing nothing more daunting than me
looking at like I'm oh this is going to
take 15 Steps for me to set up can it
just be one right or two right and so
um and so that that's that has stopped
me from contributing or you know working
on a project it's just the setup
required to get started so you might
have great documentation but if it's
like you know 10 steps I was like sorry
I don't have that time yeah you've been
thinking about video documentation you
think it's a good ideas
uh well
um maybe not I mean depends on the
contributor I mean for users I think
it's kind of uh to the point of people
are consuming things differently uh if
you can concisely pitch something in a
minute or two like and get people over
the hump to like to to try I think I
know
um just walking through someone showing
it visually I think is kind of
interesting I don't know this is
um yeah since we're virtual right you're
not not next to someone sitting sitting
and seeing what they were doing on
screen maybe that's you know uh having
someone show you is is you know uh can
you could say your activation energy
lowers your activation energy since you
don't have to read you can just consume
but I don't know that's that's something
that um I think you know if you have
Telemetry on your docs could be
something to test but I don't know yeah
yeah it's interesting like uh Pi torch
lightning has like a video on each
like function and Method and it makes me
a little bit nervous like oh how do you
maintain this because like you change
something or you're going to re-record
now
but yeah that's interesting we're all
content creators
maybe we should actually do
documentation on how to build
documentation because we really need to
learn how to do documentation that it's
actually relevant to like nowadays
targets
I just want to mention that everyone
thinks they do documentation better than
everybody else and that's why we don't
have any kind of consensus here so I
just think it's really funny because
everyone's just like this is the right
way to do it and then you know all it's
going to do is also by the way just
create 15 other people to create their
own tick tocks to tell you all the
reasons you're wrong
so the question that comes to mind when
we talk about documentation which we've
talked about quite a bit
um
is with co-pilot or you know chat gbt
what is the impact on writing
documentation going forward where we
have uh some assistant whatever it might
be some AI assistant who is potentially
reading the documentation for us or
generating that documentation and so
like what is the
and this will segue into it the next
thing we can just kind of roll into is
like what is the impact on
um co-pilots AI in open source
yeah um
so I think it's a really interesting
question
um as far as so like I'm because of
mbdev and things like that I think that
I'm I I'm really subscribed to the
literate programming
sort of ideology which is
your programs should be you know meant
to be read by the user and like writing
documentation should be part of your
software development workflow itself
because I find that when I write
software
if I if it becomes a lot better when I'm
documenting it at the same time and what
that means is
often I'll be I'll write something and
then I go to write documentation for it
at the same time and I'll realize hey
this is
really bad
I don't want to document this and then
I'll rewrite that thing and that happens
quite a lot
um
and so yeah I think that so that's one
aspect like co-pilot might help with
that but I think there's a larger issue
of like right now
the way co-pilot
is is kind of like assuming your
programming environment is like fixed in
co-pilot bringing co-pilot bringing
large language models into those Ides
but I think
like there's a lot of room for your Ides
to change to accommodate
a large language models so fundamentally
like your software development workflow
fundamentally changing
um
so yeah there's some idea if you want to
know like concrete example you can
Google roboweb is a good example it's
like a Jupiter notebook with
like a Chad gbt thing in it
um like as a sidecar in kind of like
automatically go back and forth so I
think there's a lot of other modalities
and like really we can rethink software
development
like from the perspective of hey we have
this additional tool
like us
best as we can because if nowadays you
can just like copy a python code into
chat TPT and ask what does it python
code do and then chat TPT is going to
Output a perfectly viable answer then we
should just take advantage of that to
make our own things like better I mean
writing documentation is probably going
to become more easier due to these tools
that we have available uh but again if
if uh I don't know a 18 year old
um kid is going to try to figure out how
to start using some libraries he's
probably not going to go to read the
documentation he's probably going to ask
Chad DBT or maybe use some other
resources that we have available that
are more fun to watch maybe so I think
we should like make use of these tools
but these are going to definitely
um make the education very different in
the future
okay well I'm just gonna go ahead and
say like from what I've seen so far the
state that things are in right now chat
GPT is just really good at bsing right
so I worry about all the really really
crappy copious amounts of documentation
that are going to be out there that
we're gonna have to Wade through that
actually are wrong
um first off okay on the other hand if
anything gets me out of writing
documentation I'm I'm pretty cool with
that so um if we can get this to a point
that it's really good the the thing that
I also do worry about and
um you know maybe this is something that
I shouldn't be worried about but
having an assistant write your code I
worry about Innovation as a software
developer right that like you're talking
about is that it's assuming constant
apis it's constant you know it's
assuming a certain amount of consistency
over time right but if you're a library
developer right who's having to clean
interfaces who's you know updating
things to use different libraries that
you are trying to you know use better
practices in here you're you know more
maintainable code more scalable code
more you know updating to a newer
version of something like that
is that something that it's going to be
able to do because I mean obviously
we're training on things that have
already been created right what about
all the things that are new and that I
don't see that you can necessarily get
away 100 from
a person just yet and like I'm not
saying that it's not going to happen but
you know those are my two maybe more
jaded opinions yeah I have a different
experience I feel like I'm able to be a
lot more ambitious and
kind of do projects I wouldn't think
about
because of co-pilot
um like you know I've started making vs
code extensions and I've never
really I yeah I was able to like make a
vs code extension
like within two or three hours uh like a
like a meaningful one
um anyway I don't know without any
really that like any prior experience
with typescript
um you know and things like that like
our like Chrome extensions or various
other things
and I yeah I feel and even with python
projects I feel like
it's with the thoughtful sort of
interaction I'm able to guide it now
yeah there'd be like lazy people out
there that probably
just ship the code
that you know is there but yeah I feel
like it's a powerful tool for me so far
I think actually
um that we could use that in our favor
for Innovation because like if we can't
delegate this more basic automatic tasks
to like this
sort type of robot and we can focus on
the Innovative part of whatever we want
to do then maybe it actually help us do
things faster right like what you were
saying
um if if I want to do like a new project
or whatever and maybe I don't have to
put like a lot of time to things that I
already know how to do and someone else
can do them for me and I can just think
of the how to make this new how to make
this impactful how to make this so I
think that it can also be used in our
advantage in that sense
yeah so largely agree I think I'm still
learning how to use it best but yeah if
you can use it to be increase your
efficiency right whether it's to you
know spend less or more time on on
certain things but yeah I can see it
helping create documentation what I'm
more excited about is you know when
someone creates an issue or has a
question that it can give them an answer
so when or Auto suggesting the fix even
to go back into your project like that
that's kind of where where I could see
it being useful but then there's a
question of who pays for the compute you
know but but otherwise maybe that's a
funding question but yeah yeah one
person that I recommend
reading about or following is Simon
Willison because like a notable python
programmer creator of Django and data
set all these other projects he writes a
lot about how he uses uh co-pilot and
chaji BT in his pers in his workflow and
he's he's pretty detailed about it so
yeah I actually learned a lot like got a
lot of ideas by
kind of reading what he does closely
I actually don't remember if we had 60
minutes or more than we have what
90 minutes okay
um so I I don't think we'll use the
whole 90 minutes it's been 60 Minutes
um Hamill was like I don't know how
we're gonna talk for 60 minutes and here
we are at 60 minutes and he's still
talking
um so I want to open it up and see if
there are any questions uh on any of the
topics or other topics from the audience
we can do a few questions and then maybe
wrap it up
I'll start with Jim over here
sorry I see it very much as a collective
action problem right so this is a
well-known problem right well-known
problem space we have tragedy of the
commons we know open SSL we all know
this story
and I I jokingly said blue Mark blue
check mark But Twitter is a Commons
right
and he's exploiting it right he's
basically saying you're getting value
out of this Commons
we can't do it in such a way that every
individual is for themselves so we're
treating as a collective problem
I think the check mark is not a bad one
for no Focus that's my take on it but do
you have opinions on it as a collective
action problem how do we sell those
we're not very good at it as a species I
don't think
how do you price it that's my question
I mean look you know I mean let me give
you throw something out there right a
number of downloads from them non-focus
if I want to do it if if somebody at
some large organization downloads more
than some so many every day they
certainly have to start paying right and
now suddenly you're going to get big
companies they're going to start have to
pay a bit
and then you can adjust that or whatever
but it's like
you know I think I think if we think
about it in those terms and people are
talking about a lot of the problems we
have in those terms then we can come up
with some solutions
yeah I would like to see open source
maintainers Thrive not just be quote
sustainable
you know so the notion of sustainable is
like kind of this word that implies that
you're you're okay
but I don't think that's good enough
because I think open source maintainers
a lot of time creating a lot of value
should be able yeah
yeah definitely yeah that's what I mean
yeah so like
um I would like to figure out yeah a
system where people can
move Beyond just sustaining but to
thriving somehow yeah
I was just going to say I would love for
the projects to thrive 100 I think that
sustainable right now is actually a
really good place to start is all I'm
saying
yeah
yeah I have a there's a question that
has to do with the usage of chat GPT
um have uh are you all familiar with the
paper about stochastic parrots the one
that says on the on the dangers of large
stochastic parrots that one
yes
um
like given that we are given that we
know all the stories of how their Sony
bugs out there that are in so much bad
code in production
um
I know feel free to refute me on that
and tell me about whether that's a
series of problem I as I think it is but
um
how would you um how would you advise uh
open source contributors especially new
ones to use that because
um
because like just copy pasting from chat
GPT kind of relies on the assumption
that um
whatever code is out there is already
good code
yeah yeah that's a good question I think
there's a really powerful way to use
chat GPT which is to say please explain
this code to me what are the trade-offs
of this why did you do it this way what
are some other things I should think
about that's the way I use chat gbt like
I asked like for you know I describe the
problem trying to solve it gives me some
code
if it's a kind of a more complex
kind of problem I will ask a lot of
introspective questions and then get
ideas for things that I might want to
search independently
and it kind of I don't
yeah I think the wrong way to use it is
just to blindly copy and paste code and
like put it in some code because it's
really yeah it's not you're not growing
necessarily that way
and yeah I just ask a lot of questions
about the code itself
and you sometimes ask it is there
another way to do this
and just like really kind of being still
you're still being a student but kind of
like understanding
like once you like uh practice that idea
I think it's very powerful you can learn
a lot faster
and that's what that's like the best way
I that I mean that's the way I use it
and I think yeah
what are the odds of an open source
Library landing on chat gbt especially
given like contributions or if if you
want to ask okay explain how uh explain
how this um ssk learn open source
yes okay explain how this uh line in
sklearn works
um versus uh versus some obscure project
that um that has like five contributors
I I did an experiment uh
three weeks ago and I wrote some code
that used by Wax which is
uh open source in 2022 and uh rerun
which is open sourced in 2023 and I
wrote this code and I was like oh I
don't want to write a blog post but I
need to write a blog post
so I just took chunks of the code and I
was like let's see what comes out of
this thing and I
ask questions of chat GPD about it and
like asked asked it to like write
um or explain different parts of the
code to me and I did a really really
good job and it had no clue what the the
library was and so I think that there's
like I don't know it was maybe
hallucinating in a really good way but
um the blog post I then posted and it's
it's on our website and
um
it was like one of the most successful
ones
unfortunately but uh it's just really
interesting that
um what Hamel was saying is like if
you're if you use some like critical
thinking as part of your uh engagement
with it you can actually like peel
through the layers of what's going on in
an understanding way
I'm not sure whether your question was
getting at it but
um you made me think of Licensing with
respect to what GPT outputs
um I don't know whether that's an issue
anyone's thought of but if you're
training on open source right it has a
particular license uh and so if
something say like hpl 3 and Jet GPT
verbatim take some code out of it
did it you know are you in breach of
that license that was actually what I
was going to bring up is that there's a
big question here about attribution in
general and I think sometimes people
forget that code is protected under
copyright just as is like a work a book
that is written by an author and the
same laws apply to it right and so what
there's a big question open right now
already about when you know books are
going to be written by chat GPT how do
you attribute that back to the original
authors that were used obviously if
something is within the style of
something what do you do there and along
with that by the way I do want to bring
up the idea of liability and security as
well right who is liable right for that
code when it's out there if it creates
some sort of security issue or if there
is some sort of I mean all kinds of
things can happen in code we've all seen
this um there have been you know huge
data breaches there have been huge uh
catastrophic failures of different
things within open source communities
and especially
um you know not to go too far off into a
tangent but with some of the you know
legislation that's up in Europe which
we'll end up applying to us in the
United States which we saw with gdpr
this is going to become a bigger and
bigger issue when we do have assistance
helping us write code I think these are
all open questions like what are we
going to do how do we going to handle
this and how are we going to be able to
attribute and and handle all these
things we don't necessarily want to
spend all of our time in court we want
to create cool things we want to build
cool technology so I don't have an
answer to it but I do think that this is
going to be a bigger and bigger question
as we move down this road very very
quickly
and
in your experience
experiences for a lot of years
do you feel like
the community has changed and now it's
taking a lot for granted open sources
and I'm asking you this because we can
see a lot of packages now changing also
the licensing
exactly because of that and I wanted to
know your opinion
me personally I think that you are
seeing kind of a shift I think
um
well not to get too much into my keynote
tomorrow but uh you know I think
sometimes we do have to kind of remember
where we came from in order to
understand why we're doing this why does
this matter and what are the guideposts
and what are the you know philosophies
behind why we continue to do it this way
and uh I I just I I think that a lot of
people are tired right
maintainers burn out all the time you
know I I know that there definitely been
times where I've looked at an issue and
I'm just like why am I doing this I'm
not even getting paid for this
um whereas other people could be coming
actually from a business that's making
money off this package that are the ones
asking for the support right and um I I
do think that there is a shift happening
right now
and I don't I don't know exactly where
it's going to go but I do think that
people will become a little bit more
um I guess Fed Up In some cases and in
other cases maybe even a little
mercenary
now I mean I was going to add to that
was the I think the uh the cloud
providers actually I think been a pretty
big reason for the shift in licenses
right uh since you had things like
elastic that came up with their own new
ones right
um and and then partly because yeah
they've uh they're at such a scale that
they're you know making lots of money
off of this open source stuff so I think
you know because of as they have gotten
bigger I think it's become a bigger
problem
and that's another example of a company
right that was built around and open
which was a fork by the way of an Apache
project right and so that was uh um I
don't know if anybody else was around
when that happened but it was it was
kind of a big deal and um because the
other you know what it was forked from
died on the vine right whereas elastic
was able to build a company around it
and remain sustainable and so um anyway
I'll stop
uh yeah thank you my my question is
actually about the similar topic but
from the other way around so like how to
build an open source project as a
company the right way because that's
what we're trying to do and and actually
you know we've been uh refused to become
an Associated project at num focus last
year for specifically this reason
because you know most of the
contributors come from the same company
and and things like that and it makes
total sense but uh I'm just trying to
understand uh what you know what's the
right way uh to do to do all this we we
give all our technology out there for
free uh we we are happy to take
obviously contributions we get a lot of
really valuable contributions from
people in the community uh I get a lot
of feedback we get a lot of feedback on
how to improve what we do so it seems
like a healthy uh relationship with the
community but uh still as you mentioned
it's sort of like a grayish Zone there
and and I'm just trying to understand
how to how to do things properly here to
fit the culture well I mean there's the
question of properly then there's the
criteria for being an Affiliated project
as part of dumb Focus right
um these are not necessarily the same
things I'm just gonna say it right that
there are a lot of different ways to do
open source all the way along the scale
and you know obviously I'm very very uh
involved in numb focus and things like
that but I'm involved in a lot of Open
Source things outside of numb Focus as
well and I just want to mention that you
know I agree that there that does seem
very healthy that seems like a really
great way to run a project and keep it
you know running and all of those things
like that but I think that especially
for a a community like numb Focus really
is about building Community it has that
Community Driven aspect of it and that's
why I think that that is an important
part of the criteria of becoming part of
that larger Community right and so and
especially in the sense that being a
fiscal you know sponsor of different
projects you know if we shouldn't be the
fiscal entity for a project that is
backed by a company right that just
doesn't make any sense and so I I just
want to mention that that like you're
not doing anything wrong right by doing
this I think it's a fantastic thing to
do but as being part of a numb Focus
project
being within the mission of num Focus
making sure that it's in accordance with
the same values that numb focus is
trying to push forward that is a
criteria that was added in order to be
able to ensure that is Community Driven
I was going to say part of it depends on
who your target end users are a little
since I think someone else internally in
another company using you for commercial
purposes like you driving and them
getting that value out it sounds fine
but you know for other people who are
just doing it for side projects and want
to you know better themselves as part of
the community like they have different
incentives right and so they might not
want to contribute if you're the only
one driving
um uh or at least you know that's some
of the feedback that I've been kind of
you know given in terms of you know
starting a company around open source
which I'm doing myself like a
contentious thing with uh uh Founders or
at least you get pretty different takes
is do you name the company the same as
the project or have it very or have it
very separate and distinct right
um so some some would argue you want
them both together to like you know
because you want to be the community and
have the confused but I think you know
that leads to confusion within the
community as what is open source and
what is closed Source sometimes so I
think there's there's two different ways
of thinking about yeah how do you name
things to really keep the Community side
separate from the commercial side and so
there's different takes there you know
where are the opinion so dag works is
you know very different brand from
Hamilton which is the open source side
but there's other people like you know
DBT being a famous example they actually
changed their name to be DBT just to
like capitalize on on on the open source
side of things so that that is something
to and I think we'll see play out over
the next few years as to which way is
the better way but my assumption is that
if you really want your community you
really want to have its own branded
identity that's different from from your
company
I just want to add that I do think that
this goes back to our earlier
conversation that numb Focus you know we
do we want to explore other avenues to
be a part of the community right that
it's not necessarily always you know the
Avenues we have set up right now and so
um it's an ongoing conversation
I just wanted to say that I don't think
there's a correct way of doing like an
open source Library it actually depends
on what your purpose is and if you are
building your project for the community
then a good way to evaluate if you are
doing it right or wrong would be
actually seeing what's the response of
the community of your users of your
target
um with your library like there's I
don't know there's surveys if if you
have actually open contributions what
are people saying on GitHub what are the
issues whether they're talking about
um like if you want to create a more
like
active Community around it then social
media engagement and what are they
saying on Twitter about your library are
they talking about it like good stuff
and that's like a way to see uh whether
you're doing it right or wrong but I
don't think there's like a right way to
do open sources actually means on what
goal are you are you looking for when
you're building your project
so it's certainly possible to get
funding for the Scientific Python
ecosystem because anacondas managed to
do it right I say business model so is
that something that non-focus would
consider because there's definitely
things that enterprises would want
like secure supply chain support and so
on that seem like if they were you know
if and if num Focus was supplying those
things potentially they could get those
longer term non-marketing Department
dependent sources of funding
sure so what Anaconda is and I'm just
going to go ahead and say this as a
former Anaconda employee right so I can
go ahead and put that spin on this whole
thing is that you know Anaconda is
actually you know an incredibly good
actor in the in the community and
um even to the point I don't think this
is any big uh surprise or anything but
Anaconda actually gives a percentage of
their money back to numb Focus every
quarter so this is something that you
know they've chosen to do because it's
part of that Collective that they are
you know incubating they incubate so
many projects there
um but it it has been tenuous actually
at times right it hasn't always been
quite as simple as you know building
this company around it
and you know everything just works out
beautifully or anything like that but
I I think that you know one of the nice
things about Anaconda obviously is that
Peter is a True Believer like he is 100
behind this so that makes it a lot
easier
I would love if other companies decided
to move in that same direction but it
was voluntary on their part right um
that's not something that we solicited
so um I I don't know how to encourage
that with other companies
right now I
if you have any suggestions I would love
to hear it
I had a follow-up question on the
licensing and like how kind of the
corporations use all of the
packages that are you know free
um a lot of the kind of new features
that they're asking for and like driving
for like is there a way to have that be
kind of more pay to play because I'm
hearing you guys saying like I don't
want to do this feature for this kind of
like nondescript company that's just
going to make money off of it so like
why not just say no or attach a dollar
value
I mean it depends when you draw the line
on the features you're adding to the
project probably
I mean when early on every feature you
add to the project you want to be used
by a lot of people so there's a lot more
utility added for each like
amount of energy expended
so at some point you've added all these
super you know
uh features that can be used by a lot of
the community when someone comes along
and asks for one particular feature
might be that you've already I don't
know it could be that there are so many
other people adding it but I think uh
the support and road map selling is
something that's done by companies today
I mean I think that's a a business model
I mean I think Red Hat kind of pioneered
and was successful in selling support
around open source and selling features
you could Fork your open source project
and make it completely different on your
platform
there's many ways to do it but you'll
still be deemed probably as Evil by the
maximalist open source Community
potentially I mean hashicorp
built a very successful open Core
Business we've all used their Open
Source Products probably all of us here
but as soon you know because they lead
the road map they're deemed as
an evil Corporation behind an open
source product
there's no real I think there's still a
lot of
problems in the licensing today because
you have a definition of what open
source is based on the license
you can't always
the value that you create you cannot
always capture that and so the business
might not exist or it exists in a way
that's deemed you know not open source
anymore so
yeah there are many ways to do it but
not all of them work for sure yeah they
stop becoming open source at some point
I mean so people uh I mean you see a lot
more GitHub repos now with like licenses
actually some different directories of
different licenses and stuff and so
that's something you need to pay
attention to
um uh but yeah that's that's something
you know I've been thinking about as
well you know like how do you license
something such that you know uh uh if
someone wants to take it to production
commercially like you know there should
be some limits or other things in regard
and so
um but yeah no I think we'll we'll see
what sticks in five years or so if they
come but I mean if the company dies the
open source Project's still there I
think in the current economic
environment we'll see many companies
that probably uh aren't going to live up
to the promise of what they're going to
be around their open source community
and they might not grow into what they
were promising these like commercial
open source companies so we're still
witnessing like a change in what uh
business model will be we don't you know
it's not a like cotton dry thing today
I mean just to add to that I mean that's
one of the reasons that we want to have
more than one entity involved in a
project as part of num focus is that I
mean sustainability is not just about
money it's about being able to move
forward so if people you know if a
company fails which you know happens all
the time does that project go away right
it's almost as just as bad as somebody
graduates with their PHD and then they
go away right we still want to have
those mechanisms in place in order for
something to move forward
actually there I have seen uh there's
some licenses that you know aren't open
source so I think Maria DB has one where
effectively they say it's open code you
can't use it for production but in four
years it becomes open source source
available yes awesome that by the way is
incredibly uh
controversial right now okay it's not
it's not technically open source until
it becomes Apache or 2.0 or MIT
or whatever copy left
but it happened because the clouds were
taking advantage of
um software and they were not
contributing back yeah but yeah and then
um also you know if you're going to
stick a thing on a company and you're
small being having the code AS open
source is kind of an insurance policy
right and so in which case I think
that's the other the other angle of that
license
so at the very beginning what you're
looking for is maximum adoption there's
a certain number of there are companies
out there that have like a uh software
supply chain do not use list and it
might include some of that some of those
licenses so if you want maximum
penetration and Adoption of your
software you're going to end up using
MIT or some super permissive license and
and that kind of you know you you end up
in this same situation
that you know the free software movement
versus open source is always kind of a
gray area people get confused a lot open
source for sure that term of art was
actually you know it's very pragmatic
that that idea of like you know free and
fair use maximum adoption like you were
talking about it's kind of a middle
ground and um yeah and but once again
you put something out into the wild you
choose your license choose your own
destiny it's all good
and
pray for the more complex larger open
source projects
see any threat from free serverless
services like we're seeing that if you I
mean you can take Gmail Dropbox you know
seeing a databases you see the machine
learning we see it with these experiment
tracking tools they're all free now and
there's so much free service achievement
Services it's all free poking face
ownership
it's a wave of
open source nothing get your thing as
they get
you but this is
me no like I just
um you know it depends on you know
the threat is to money right that's
completely separate from whether or not
something is open source in my mind
right so you know when people talk about
competitions and threats and all of
these things like that I truly do go
back to you know the idea of like the
whole idea
is to get ideas out there
and so um yeah that's my short answer I
mean it might kill some startups that's
about it
thanks
um going back to the uh chat GPT and
co-pilot uh topic so a couple of you
mentioned you know that just copying and
pasting what it generates is a terrible
idea and I totally agree with you
um on the other hand thousands you know
maybe hundreds of thousands of
developers a day do exactly the same
thing
um from stack Overflow right they just
copy and paste has has anyone studied
you know is the quality of code you get
by copying pasting from one any better
or worse than the other or you know is
is chat gbd trained enough on the on
stack Overflow that it's the same exact
stuff
yeah I mean I don't think it's always
bad to copy and paste from chat gbt
there's a lot of low stakes code out
there like you know stuff I want to
automate for myself or something I don't
know it's like so like there's so many
people out there just want to rename a
directory of Excel files or something
it's like easy to verify so I mean
there's yeah like I I wouldn't like made
blanket statement like okay you should
never copy and paste
code is like the same thing the same
goes for stack Overflow code like I
think people copy and paste stack
Overflow code
mostly when it's like
pretty it's like a pretty scoped thing
that they can easily verify if it's
working and it makes sense when they see
it they they say aha that's exactly what
I want
it's kind of similar like with stack
Overflow you get like an explanation
maybe and there's like comments but like
oh yeah this Edge case and this Edge
case gives you more confidence that
works because like from humans it's
somewhat verifiable or give like just
gives you more Trust
but I think it's kind of similar in that
way like
you you do want to copy and paste but
you copy and paste and select
situations
that's my answer anyway
I think that my short answer is I have
no idea which one is better like but
um I honestly think that we should not
say no to just like copy paste code
because I think that there's even some
like very experienced developers who are
actually in stock over full flow like
helping people writing their code and
it's like it's I think it's us who has
have to do like the the homework of
knowing what to trust and not like what
to not trust but in any case if it's
chatty PT or if it's stack Overflow in
both cases we need to be cautious of
what we are using and how we're using it
but
um I don't think it's like a hard no on
copy pasting code because I think that
I mean there there's going to be a point
in which we're going to be able to do
that from job TPT and it's gonna like
maybe even be better than us like doing
code but at this point it's just like a
matter of caution and select what you
use and how you use it
just one more kind of I think the right
way to use stack Overflow also
is like to learn something you know it's
like to say Hey you see a piece of code
is like oh why does it do that or what
is that thing here that I don't
understand
um you know if you just the same thing
with Chad GPT it's like but the child
GPT you know you have to put in the
effort maybe to like write the question
or like dig a little bit Sac overflow
maybe it's already there someone else
has a question in the comments or
something so I think it's like again
similar like you try to learn something
is the idea
that's it we're at time we're at time
thank you everybody thank you
thank you for the panelists